Amazon wants their employees to resign
this might sound counter-intuitive but
it's true they likely spend thousands if
not tens of thousands of dollars on
recruiting each into every one of their
employees so it doesn't really make
sense to sign them on it just for
two-thirds of warehouse workers to leave
in 90 days and that their Tech workers
to leave in two years right wrong it
turns out that constantly turning to
employees is not only cheaper for Amazon
but substantially more productive in
fact Jeff Bezos has gone as far as
declaring that a tenured Workforce is
simply a march to mediocrity as
employees become more tenured they tend
to also become more comfortable and more
lazy essentially they want you to come
in with the Big Dreams work your ass off
for two years realize that no one
recognizes your efforts and then leaves
so that the neck sucker can come in and
do the exact same thing